- [Interviewer] All right, we have Larry,
Larry Rob, Amanda's father,
and we have Lima who has a
plan in how to help Amanda.
Welcome Lima.
Welcome Larry.
- Hello.
- Larry,
you haven't even seen any of the videos
I've shot of Amanda, right?
- No, because after hearing them,
hearing about them I figured,
well, I had seen the day
to day, the slideshow.
So I'm living it.
So I've not watched the video.
- [Interviewer] No, I recommend you don't.
First off, let me clarify something.
Amanda said some things in
her first interview with me
about you,
that your oldest daughter
wanted me to clarify
and make sure everyone understood
they were not true.
Amanda says some crazy things
when she comes in here,
and she says 'em about everybody.
So it's not just you.
She said the same thing
about many, many people.
So whatever Amanda said about her father
in that first video,
it's a bunch of nonsense.
So I just wanted to say that.
So Larry, tell me a little
bit about your life.
You have, how many children?
- I have four children.
I have three girls and one boy.
- [Interviewer] And
Amanda is your youngest.
- Amanda is my youngest child.
- [Interviewer] And
tell me about your life.
You were a war veteran.
- Yes, I went into the air force.
I had some scholarships
offered out of high school,
but I chose to do a university
and it was quite expensive,
so I chose the air force
'cause I wanted to travel.
So after choosing that then
all sort of opportunities opened up.
I was kind of a young guy
having fun, going around.
Had some good deployments.
The air force was very good to me.
I did 11 and a half years there.
So, travel and all of that sort of
fill those young man
intuitions have something to do
that was beyond me.
So that was an experience
I'll never, never forget.
And I'm still having benefits
from it 45 years later.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
So the issues with
Amanda had been going on
for about how long?
- Since September of 2016.
- [Interviewer] How did it start?
She was in college, right?
- Yeah, she and I.
She was at the CSUN, Cal State Northridge.
She had had a successful
elementary and high school.
She went to a chartered
high school because
as a single parent, I say, well,
let me just do whatever I
can to fill in the blank.
Give her that extra edge for, projectory,
trajectory.
So she did very, very well in high school.
And she went to CSUN.
She was doing very well.
She was a critical thinker, a writer.
So she was doing well in her classes.
But then she started to not show up
when I would visit her during the mid week
to take her her groceries.
I was at the university myself.
She challenged me.
So I said, okay, I went into Domingus.
So that's why I was at the university
because she challenged me.
So I went to get a degree
in sociology at that time,
but I was going up there
as a parent twice a week,
and she would disappear.
And then she started to tell me
that she was being surveilled.
And I said, "Oh no,"
I'm thinking from my military days,
I said, "they don't
even have the resources
"to keep up with you, Amanda Bear."
So that's kinda how this started.
And then after a few
months of not seeing her,
she had established some new
friends that I never met,
I had her diagnosed and it
was schizophrenia bipolar.
And that was September of 2016.
- [Interviewer] And then she
started using crack, right?
- She started using crack.
That was the following year.
First when she started,
she started using meth.
Meth scared her.
In counseling she said, "Oh my gosh."
She looked at me in a way
that I knew she was sincere.
She said, no, meth scared her.
So she stopped using meth
after the first six, seven, eight months.
This is from looking back on it,
because at the time I didn't
know she was using drugs.
So she was starting to
talk about using crack.
So she began to use crack in 2017.
So she's been using crack.
She had used meth a couple times,
from time to time,
but she's been using,
I mean cocaine since then.
- [Interviewer] So you
and I have been struggling
with Amanda all of this
year and some of last year.
- Every day,
every day.
- But you've been
on the front lines.
You're her father.
So you've been seeing it from the start.
But you've seen some crazy,
crazy behavior, right?
I mean, Amanda jumps out of cars.
She gets beaten up.
She walks around through the night.
- The extreme.
- Barefoot?
- Oh, the extreme.
First, the first year and a half or so
she was down in LA,
Florence, Western, Vermont,
Manchester, those areas.
So it was quite different for me
because I had to go there
just to catch up with her every day.
So that's what I did.
I put it on my agenda.
Everyday I would go there.
So I had not seen her for
like three or four days.
So I was gonna go to 77th and
make an MIA, missing person.
I was already, she was on
the front seat of the bus.
I got onto the bus.
I didn't recognize her.
So I went on and sat down.
After a stop or so she came back to me,
and that different person
that I saw, I didn't know.
She was right in front of my face.
I felt so bad.
To this day I felt so bad
because I didn't know her at first.
So after I recognized her,
she just looked up at me
and talked to me the way she always does.
She said, "Dad."
I said, "Honey, what you need?"
So I said, "Let's go get you some,
"get you an outfit."
So we did that.
She just wanted to smoke.
After we got her outfit, got
her shoes and everything,
she looked so nice.
She just said to me,
she say, "I'm thirsty.
"I just wanna go smoke."
So it took me a half hour.
So I walked up and down
Manchester with her.
So, I let her go and smoke.
So after that, it was day to day.
And then she disappeared on me.
I did MIA,
and they found her.
She was in the hospital.
Thank God.
And I was trying to do a conservatorship,
but I didn't have my ducks in line.
So they released her.
So I didn't see her for awhile.
And the VA moved me downtown
for a section eight housing.
So I didn't see her.
And I, I'm sorry.
- [Interviewer] What was Amanda
like before this happened?
- She was just such a,
she was almost eloquent to me.
She was always, "Yes dad,
please dad, excuse me dad."
And I just did every, I
kinda relive my childhood.
So she got everything she really wanted.
Disneyland, Knotts Berry,
all that every year.
Come on, Dodger Stadium.
I think I was more on the hot dogs and...
You know what I'm saying.
She had a good childhood.
All the concerts I could get her into.
And Nikia.
And you know what I'm saying?
As long as the parent could
take them, I took her.
So she had a good childhood.
She was having a good
time at the university.
It's just a set of friends I never met.
And I was almost certain
that there was something
in that relationship
that caused her to stray.
So after day to day down
there, I didn't see her.
And I was coming in from church one Sunday
and I saw Amanda downtown,
and she saw me, and it was such a relief.
And then I had been
helping her and I met Mark.
And every day it's the challenge.
It's different.
It's just-
- [Interviewer] One day
she disappeared for a week.
One day she-
- She'd been ran over by a car.
She had all her lower and
upper teeth knocked out.
She's just challenging
because of her behavior now.
She only feels like the
drug gives her relief.
- [Interviewer] There's absolutely
no way to stop this girl
from getting the drugs she wants.
- No.
- [Interviewer] There
was one time that I was,
you might remember, I was
trying to take her to the clinic
to get the prescription
for her schizophrenia,
for the medication she needs.
And as soon as she figured out that I
wasn't taking her to my studio,
she backs her legs up and start,
she was gonna kick the
windows out of my car
to get out of a moving vehicle.
(laughing)
So I had to let her out.
- She'll bolt.
No, she'll bolt.
She'll bolt, she's done that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
she'll jump out of the car.
- She's been injured three or four times
because she jumps out of cars.
She's lost her sense
of defense and danger.
Danger, danger, stranger, stranger.
She and I, she never had to engage
with strange people as a child,
from daycare to school.
You know what I mean.
So now it's just totally different.
She's walkin' around Skid Row.
- Barefoot.
Sometimes come in-
- No pants on.
- No clothes.
I've given her outfit.
'Cause that's what I do.
Every day I go out, I get her something.
'Cause you gotta have some pants.
Mark has given her clothes.
So she was just no longer
in control of her behavior.
She no longer had a sense
of, okay, this is respectful.
This is harmful.
This is not good.
- And Larry, you and I speak
on the phone very often.
- Very often.
- [Interviewer] And so
many times we've said
we just need a miracle,
'cause nothing is happening.
- We had to have one.
- [Interviewer] And nothing seems to work.
The 5150s, the cops pick her up,
and they just let her go right away.
- And then the difference
maker is she assaulted me,
because I was cooperative.
I was glad to know that I could help her
manage her benefits every month
so she don't just run out in a few days.
But after she assaulted
me the second time,
I said I have to do something differently.
And then we got a call
from Mark about Lima.
And when I heard about
someone that may help us...
At the time I had some
of the professionals
in the mental health field
here in LA trying to help me.
But all they were doing was counseling me.
Amanda was comin' in and
out of that door every day,
creating a problem.
- [Interviewer] One of my friends is a,
is like the head of the West Side of LA's
AA, NA groups, all the addiction groups.
And he, I was telling him about Amanda.
And he said with people like that,
there's nothing you can do.
You just have to let 'em go.
You can't stop them.
There's no helping them.
- So this is a miracle.
'Cause I've seen that day to day.
And I thank you, Mark, for
introducing me to Lima and Ivan.
What a blessing.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
then along comes Lima.
So let me explain what you do.
Aura, your company, is not a rehab.
It's a technology that
rehabs can use, right?
How would you describe what you guys do?
- So I would say that we're
a digital health company,
and I noticed that from
the previous videos
maybe there was a little bit of confusion,
but we are not a hospital.
We are not a clinic.
We work with hospitals and clinics.
And the way, I think the best way to
really say how I, what I do is that
imagine if cars came without speedometers
and that you had to guess
how fast you were going,
and the statistic was that 90% of cars
don't make it to their destination.
And so that's how the treatment
centers are right now.
So without measurement,
how do you know you're getting better?
How many treatment centers
has Amanda been to?
- Probably seven or eight.
- And so everyone that I've spoken to,
they've been to,
way up there, like so
many treatment centers.
I've never met somebody that
went one time and it worked.
In 10% of cases, going to
treatment is successful.
90% of the time those patients
don't get to their destination,
and we don't measure it.
So it's the,
so what my company does
is we make the metrics
to measure how a patient is doing
throughout the treatment process.
- [Interviewer] That rehabs will use.
- Exactly.
So we just make the technology,
and we give it to doctors and therapists,
and so we're not changing
the way that therapy is given.
We're enhancing therapy.
So the tools, the evidence-based
therapies, they do work.
They've been proven to work.
But where the issue comes in is that
we kind of treat, like
a lot of times doctors
will treat patients with
a one size fits all.
So doctors like we talked
about in the first video
are most likely to diagnose you
with what they're most
comfortable treating.
Misdiagnosis is completely
rampant with mental health.
And so when it comes to diagnosis,
when it comes to treatment,
most doctors are gonna
diagnose and treat you
with what they're most comfortable with
because there are so many
overlapping factors that look,
they all look very similar,
whether you're bipolar,
borderline personality,
chronically depressed,
a lot of them have some of
the same elements there.
And so it's very easy to get confused.
It's human error.
It's not the fault of the doctor.
It's the fault of our entire system
that we don't give mental
health professionals
tools to treat patients.
- [Interviewer] That's
what your company does.
- That's exactly what we do.
So we just offer these
tools for health detection
to help guide the doctor to
see if the type of therapy
that they're giving
this patient is working
and to measure the metrics so that
we can say this patient is not getting
to where they need to be,
let's try something else.
Right now I'm fine versus
I'm fine versus I'm fine.
Those are all different.
But like everyone hears just the words,
but we're not really listening
to how the patient is saying it.
We're not detecting physically
how they're feeling.
And we need to work in different ways
to make sure that those 90% of cars
that don't make it to their destination,
how do we make sure that across the board
all treatment is the same
and that we use one uniform measurement
so that a Medicare treatment
center is not lesser
than a high-end treatment
center that's private pay?
How do we get a unified, take
the highest care of treatment
and scale it across the board for everyone
and have that as the standard
for mental health care?
- [Interviewer] So last
week was very interesting.
That was the first week
that you've been involved
in Amanda's life.
- Yes, absolutely.
- [Interviewer] And Larry, tell
me what happened last week.
- Last week, early morning,
you gotta be at court 8:30.
- [Interviewer] Amanda's in jail.
- Amanda's, she's in jail for an assault.
- [Interviewer] An assault on you.
- On me.
- With a pipe.
- With the pipe.
So she's coming to her second court date,
and she's expecting release.
So Amanda is very provocative.
She's talking as she's coming in.
- [Interviewer] So Amanda's 24, right?
- 24.
- [Interviewer] She's an adult, right?
- Yeah, she knows at 21, she
started to making that call.
- [Interviewer] And you can't decide
that she needs to go to rehab.
- No.
- She's an adult.
- After the first six
months then she took 21
and said, "Now remember, I'm an adult."
So that was it.
So early morning, 8:30,
she's been lock up now for a few weeks.
She has a court date,
but we have to petition to
try to get conservatorship.
And Miss Lima shows up and petitions.
Her appearance and her
presence made the difference,
because I would have known what to say,
but the way she presented
it, it was so authentic.
And they knew that this is
for real, these are sponsored.
These are people that's gonna
help my family, help Amanda.
- [Interviewer] I can't
imagine anyone more motivated
than someone who's got a startup company,
and they're doing something like this
on social media, on a high
profile social media channel.
You've got everything to lose.
- What courage, what, yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's a
perfect scenario in my eyes.
Not only is Lima courageous enough to
try to help your child,
who's one of the toughest
cases on my channel,
but she's also a perfect candidate
because she's not gonna
drop the ball here.
There's too many eyes on her.
- No.
She's shown that.
Her presence, like I
said, made the difference.
Being from that military mind,
when you show up that means we're ready
to take care of our
mission planning today.
So when she said that she
was gonna help the family,
that's something I will never let go,
because everybody understood that.
Not just Amanda, but to help
Amanda will help the family.
And that just, that's the difference
in all of our association thus far.
- And so I've been very lucky
that Larry and his family are,
will drop everything and just try.
Larry always tells me, he's
like, anything you need,
I'll drop everything
and I'll be there.
- Larry's the best.
- Anything.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, 'cause imagine,
most of the dads down here on Skid Row,
they're deadbeat dads.
They're addicts.
They're alcoholics.
They're not there for their kids.
Larry is the opposite of that.
- And not to mention every single time,
like Larry's a single father-
- Yeah, she'll jump
out of the car.
- So there's so, so, so,
so many responsibilities
that come with having someone
that has a mental illness,
that needs a guardian 24 seven,
that when you don't hear
from her for an hour,
something could have happened.
And he's been dealing with
all of that responsibility.
Everything's on his shoulders,
and all the worries are on his shoulders.
And there was a day when Amanda
didn't call Larry from jail,
and he was worried about her.
And I told him, I'm like,
"Larry, today's your day
"to just take a deep breath and relax
"and remember take care of yourself,
"because Amanda needs you."
And so it's just so
incredible to have someone
that anyone would look at Amanda and say,
oh, this girl can't get help.
I've met...
We have a team of therapists
that we're working with,
and I've been going through,
'cause we're putting
together a team of people.
We have a case manager for Amanda.
So that person will be there
along the entire route.
- [Interviewer] These are
well-known, reputable.
- Yeah, very, very.
So these are all, when it comes
to what you were mentioning
about a 5150, if she were to get picked up
and put under a 5150,
which has been done before,
that's a three-day hold.
The system's so packed.
So there's so many people that need help,
but it's just so expensive.
There's not a lot of staff.
And the reason that it's expensive
is because these people
need so much attention
and so much care.
And for these healthcare
providers, it's exhausting.
Everywhere you go,
every day when you go into
work there's a confrontation.
This person is yelling
at you or they're upset
or it's a very, very stressful job.
And a lot of these facilities,
they have nurses, they have doctors,
but when you go to the
lower-end facilities,
they don't do one-on-one care.
They have more patients than doctors.
When you go to the higher-end facilities,
they do a lot more one-on-one,
and then they they just get
really up there in price.
So what I was just speaking
about regarding the petition,
we had, I think, 800 people sign it.
So it is really important,
and it's not in the sense
of supporting my company.
It's in the sense of
supporting some sort of metric
to measure how somebody
is doing in treatment.
And, again, taking that and
making it across the board.
- [Interviewer] Larry,
tell me what happened
in court last week.
- Yeah, there, she was, Miss Lima.
She's comin' to support us.
And after she talks to the
DA and the public defender
we have Amanda's case second.
They called her because they know, okay,
she gets them from, she requests,
they come from downstairs with her
because she asked them to bring her on.
Let's go.
So it was just such a blessing
to have that encourage,
that personal assistance just there.
So Amanda came out,
looking so much better.
She sounds so clear.
Like I said, she was just
coming out petitioning.
Now who makes this decision?
Do I go home today?
I have some place else to live.
I don't have to go to my...
She had all of her
presentation ready to go.
So the judge, he was very accommodating,
but he let her know did the
attorney tell you, he's gonna?
Yes, the attorney admitted,
"Yeah, I've told her what to expect."
So the next question
came, she was telling me,
"Put some money on my books."
Those kinda things was coming.
She didn't stop talking.
She stopped talking briefly.
And then the judge talked to her.
He presented the case and he told her.
- [Interviewer] And she's
been in jail for how long?
About a month, right?
- About a month, six weeks.
- [Interviewer] And no crack?
- No crack.
Talking very-
- [Interviewer] Had she been taking her
schizophrenia medication?
- Yes, I talked to her clinician,
a nurse Gomez.
He's very accommodating.
He said she's cooperating,
eating, talking to him,
taking her meds every day.
So the judge talked to
her, told her her case.
And she said to him, he said to her
would she be up for long-term care?
He said it very, at the
end of his presentation.
And she said, "Yes."
- [Interviewer] Amanda
chose the longer rehab.
- She said, "Yes, unequivocally."
She had, she just said, yeah.
- [Interviewer] You guys told me that,
I couldn't believe it.
- That was her good old yes.
I remember that kinda yes.
- [Interviewer] She chose the longer rehab
as opposed to a shorter
one, that's amazing.
- She just said yes to the longer rehab.
- Yeah, so she had the
option of being released
a week ago when I was here,
and just going back
and having her own plan
or there, or we, I'm not
gonna say the exact date,
but the end of the month
she could stay in jail and
wait until another court date.
And so they told her that
I'm working with her father
to help put in,
put her in a program and have
a long-term plan for her.
And if she would consider to stay in jail
a little bit longer and
postpone her court date,
but they need her to say okay
to not hold court that day
so that they can review
all of our paperwork,
what the program is, which
treatment center she would go to,
and if they put the
conservatorship through,
then basically the
jailhouse would coordinate
the transportation directly
from jail to treatment.
And so Amanda said, yes.
She could have made our
job extremely difficult.
And she was actually, she seemed very,
like she had something to look forward to.
- Yes, and yesterday she
confirmed what Lima is saying.
She said on the phone call, she said,
"I'm so glad I called you today."
She said, "You really have a
good rehab for me to go to?"
And I said, "Yes, this
lady is the real deal."
And she said, "Are you sure?"
I said, "Yes."
She said, "I can't hear you."
I go, why she can't hear me.
And I said, "Yes, we have a good rehab
for you to go into when you leave there."
And she says, "Oh, I'm so
glad I called you today."
And that's how she left me yesterday.
- [Interviewer] She's clear headed now.
- Yeah, she's just totally on it.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Wonderful.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thank God.
- [Interviewer] It'll be a long road.
I'm sure there'll be some setbacks.
- It's a journey, yes.
- [Interviewer] And all that,
but this is a great start.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So Lima
came out of nowhere.
- [Larry] She did, what a blessing.
I say out of the sky.
(Lima laughing)
- Thank you, Larry.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Thanks you guys,
thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Wonderful.
Thank you, Mark.
- [Mark] Mmhmm.